[Music]  Detective Inspector Oscar milks focax  yourself see a few questions  did you know miss Cavell we were  neighbors she was always kind to me so  you didn't hear anything  no 28 year old Veronique rutted fell  from her apartment building and what  appears to be a suicide alleged war  criminal officially identified his  daughter's body did you know that only  Cavell  Sophia please look after it for me it  was a woman in me an abaya she's blind  [Music]  is it true that the loss of one sense  sharpens the others I'm being followed  these people kill every day  [Applause]  whatever game you think you're playing  you just stumbled into someone else's  you don't have to do this  [Applause]  [Music]